bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo dans cette émission je vous emmène
en grèce à athènes
un an après l'accession au pouvoir
d'alexis tsipras ce nous avons été à
leur encontre de ces grecs déçus par
leur premier ministre mais tout d'abord
un rendez vous exceptionnel harlem désir
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes est notre invité est avant
de l'interroger nous nous sommes posé la
question de cette crise britannique et
qui intéresse les institutions
européennes depuis plusieurs mois le
break site caisse a causé si mon blog
qui nous en parle
brrr exit la grande bretagne vers la
sortie
c'est la nouvelle crise que traverse
l'union européenne promesse controversée
de david cameron s'il était réélu
premier ministre du royaume uni en
janvier 2015
ce référendum devrait se tenir en juin
2016 objectif donner des gages qu'en
euro sceptiques anglais mené par le
leader des you keep nigel farrage
toujours au plus haut des sondages mais
également obtenir des concessions de la
part de l'union sur la gestion des flux
migratoires et ce temps là ce n'est pas
question de race de couleur ou de
croyance mais du peuple anglais qui est
le premier concerné mesures
particulièrement controversé le premier
ministre veut notamment limiter l'accès
aux prestations sociales pour les
étrangers y compris communautaire un
dispositif qui va à l'encontre de la
charte des droits fondamentaux et du
principe d'égalité des ressortissants
européens
si le chef du parti conservateur appel
dès maintenant à voter non avec ce
référendum
david cameron joue son avenir politique
ainsi que celui de son pays
bonjour harlem désir bonjour n'aura m'a
dit vous êtes secrétaire d'état chargé
des affaires européennes autant dire
qu'en ce moment vous ne gérer que des
crises je vais commencer par la première
d'entre elles en l'occurrence la sortie
potentielle de la grande bretagne de
l'espace européen
je kiffe ce qu'il reste quand même
l'objectif effectivement et qu'il reste
on voit qu'il ya une des propositions
qui fait extrêmement polémique celle de
permettre à david cameron et son
gouvernement d'exclure les
ressortissants européens des aides
sociales pendant quatre ans est ce que
l'europe est prête à tordre le bras
entre guillemets à ses valeurs et à
créer une inégalité entre les européens
pour permettre à david cameron de rester
dans l'union européenne
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
grande bretagne le royaume uni reste
dans l'union européenne
nous pensons que c'est l'intérêt de
l'union européenne qui doit être unie
dans ses moments comme vous l'avez dit
où il ya énormément de crises auxquelles
nous faisons face ensemble mais c'est
aussi l'intérêt bien compris je crois du
royaume uni qui a tout à gagner à rester
avec ses alliés dans l'union européenne
et a continué à prendre part à toutes
les grandes politiques européennes
il ya eu une volonté de la part du
premier ministre david cameron
d'organiser un référendum c'est un débat
très ancien qui lui a permis une
réélection 112 c'était un de ses
engagements de campagne
et donc ce référendum va amener les
citoyens britanniques à se prononcer sur
une question très simple en apparence
rester ou sortir de l'union européenne
mais le premier ministre a souhaité
assortir cette décision d'une
négociation avec les autres états
membres de l'union européenne sur des
réformes au sein de l'union européenne
nous tous qui peut aller dans le sens
d'une amélioration du fonctionnement de
l'union européenne et un certain nombre
de demandes de david cameron qui porte
sur la simplification du fonctionnement
de l'union européenne sur la
compétitivité plus haut mais on sait que
ce sera facile de jean claude juncker a
dit jean claude juncker nouveau
président de la commission européenne a
recentré les politiques de l'union
européenne sur quelques priorités que
l'europe ne s'occupe plus de tout et
n'importe quoi qui s'occupe des
questions importantes la croissance
l'emploi et puis maintenant les
merranderie mais il ya d'autres demandes
vous en avez mentionné une qui peuvent
peut-être posé des problèmes par rapport
aux principaux traité d'union européenne
lorsqu'il s'agit de refuser la
discrimination entre les citoyens de
l'union européenne en matière par
exemple d'accès aux aides sociales s'il
s'agit de lutter contre des abus des
personnes qui viendraient dans un autre
pays de l'union européenne juste pour
bénéficier d'un certain nombre d' aides
sociales nous en sommes d'accord
d'ailleurs la cour de justice a eu à se
prononcer sur des cas qui concerne
d'autres pays que que la grande bretagne
qui vont dans le même sens et je crois
que ça ne pose pas de problème donc nous
nous disons tout ce qui va dans le sens
de renforcer l'union européenne nous en
sommes d'accord mais nous ne voulons pas
remettre en cause les principes
fondateurs de l'union européenne les
politiques communes et nous voulons pas
non plus qu'il y ait des dispositions
qui pourraient elles à venir gêner ceux
qui veulent aller plus loin notamment
les pays de la zone euro donc il ya des
pays ennemis dans la terrasse sur
l'intégration dans l'approfondissement
dans les politiques qu'est ce que vous
diriez quand même que david cameron
là-dedans fait une forme de chantage à
l'union européenne c'est à dire que il
faut qu'il ait réussi à négocier ceci
pour que lui de son côté fasse campagne
pour un non à la sortie de la
grande-bretagne
bon je crois pas je crois qu'il va
vouloir sans doute se prévaloir après la
discussion qui aura lieu au prochain
conseil européen au mois de février en
effet voilà dans un certain nombre de
de gains disons dans cette discussion
dire qu'il a été entendu
nous pensons que c'est bien d'entendre
les préoccupations d'un état membre
mais encore une fois nous ne voulons pas
lâcher non serre ne voulons pas changer
les traités parce qu'on va pas se lancer
maintenant dans une grande révision des
traités qui prendrait des années
d'ailleurs alors que je crois qu'il ya
des urgences donc en gros cette
politique en fait de discrimination
vis-à-vis de ressortissants européens
c'est niet
mais il ya des traités qui disent qu'on
peut pas traiter différemment des
citoyens nationaux ou d'autres pays de
l'union européenne mais encore une fois
ça n'interdit pas de lutter contre des
abus alors en l'occurrence la grande
bretagne et la france viennent une
nouvelle fois d'être ciblés par l'état
islamique dans le cadre d'une vidéo de
revendication des attentats en indiquant
qu' une fois de plus l'europe seraient
touchés certainement à grande ampleur au
repos l'a confirmé donc l' agence
européenne chargée de la lutte contre la
criminalité
la france a réussi à pousser pour que le
pnr le fameux fichier des noms des
passagers soit votée il va falloir
certainement deux ans pour que cela soit
appliqué c'est à dire transposer dans
les pays
ça nous renvoie peut-être à une
politique un petit peu petit bras en ce
qui concerne la lutte contre le
terrorisme à ce qu'on est à la hauteur
messieurs ministre d'abord c'est une
priorité absolue vous l'avais dit la
menace terroriste elle est là elle est
plus élevé que jamais mais n'oublions
pas qu'il ya eu des attentats aussi en
belgique y en a eu et a capella et qu'il
y en a eu dans d'autres pays que les
pays de l'union européenne et des
importants en tunisie à bamako à jakarta
donc il y a en tout cas pour ce qui est
des pays de l'union européenne une
nécessité absolue à prendre des
dispositions qui sont à la fois celle de
l' échange d'informations entre les
services de police pas acceptable que
les fichiers qui sont faits pour cela ce
d'europol vous les avez mentionné ce
d'interpol ceux du service d'information
schengen ne soit pas renseigné par les
différents services sur des personnes
qui représenterait un danger parce qu'on
sait qu'elle se sont rendus par exemple
en syrie mais comme en conséquence on le
voit bien que les services ne veulent
pas ne fonctionne pas ensemble on a bien
très bien et c'est une des choses que
bernard cazeneuve a demandé encore lors
d'une réunion qui a eu lieu cette
semaine à amsterdam entre des ministres
de l'intérieur il ya le contrôle des
frontières extérieures communes
il faut pas faire d'amalgamé avec les
réfugiés mais nous le savons notamment
depuis les attentats de paris et saint
denis
il y a évidemment de la part des groupes
terroristes l'utilisation aussi
deux sets et réfugiés oui pour ceux
s'immiscer au milieu des réfugiés avec
des faux documents
puisque l'état islamique en irak et en
syrie a récupéré des passeports des
passeports authentiques mais qui sont
ensuite délivré à des personnes de façon
frauduleuse pour essayer de pénétrer en
europe donc mais comme toutes ces
dispositions qui sont absolument
prioritaire et il faut reconnaître que
l'europe a pris du retard parce que
l'europe a été prise au dépourvu par
cette crise de la sécurité cette crise
des réfugiés
ils sont deux choses différentes mais
qui se cumulent pour mettre l'europe à
l'épreuve parce que l'europe n'avait pas
été bâti sur les questions de sécurité
et historiquement elle a été bâtie pour
s'occuper de questions économiques le
marché commun la politique agricole
commune la monnaie commune mais
aujourd'hui des questions principales
pour son avenir pour la sécurité de ses
citoyens pour sa cohésion
ce sont les questions de sécurité alors
vous évoquez là l'autre crise qui nous
occupe depuis déjà quelques mois qui est
la crise des réfugiés
robert fico premier ministre slovaque
parle aussi de fiasco total sur la
gestion en fait du système des quotas
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
on peut pas vraiment lui objecter que ce
système fonctionne oui mais je vous
raconte ne peut pas penser que l'europe
réagira bien si chaque pays se replie et
si on refuse la solidarité donc il y a
eu des décisions qui ont été prises en
matière de réponse à la crise des
réfugiés s'étaient même avant les
attentats terroristes qui sont à la fois
d'exercer mieux le contrôle aux
frontières extérieures communes en
mettant en place en particulier des
centres d'enregistrement qu'on avait eu
des olas vote ont toujours pas
véritablement mis en place six doivent
être mis en place en grèce 6 doivent
être mis en place en italie ils ne sont
pas encore tous opérationnels et c'est
une urgence là aussi absolue et il faut
absolument que tous les états membres
envoient des policiers qui sont
spécialisés dans la police des
frontières des agents des offices de
réfugiés des personnels qui renforce
l'agencé frontex pour permettre que ces
hotspots fonctionne et qu'on contrôlent
les identités de ceux qui viennent
comptage ceux qui peuvent relever de
l'asile et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
relever de l'asie mais ceux qui peuvent
relever de l'asile nous sommes engagés à
les accueillir une façon solidaire c'est
ce qu'on appelle la relocalisation
on peut pas dire que c'est simplement la
grèce et l'italie qui doivent accueillir
des réfugiés qui viennent de syrie par
exemple qui fuient la guerre et qui
veulent aller en europe ne veulent pas
aller spécialement en grèce ou en italie
donc il y a eu un engagement qui a été
pris ça peut pas être simplement
l'allemagne ou la suède ou la france
parce que nous accueillons beaucoup de
demandeurs d'asile contrairement à ce
qui est dit parfois il ya eu une
augmentation
d'ailleurs l'an dernier et lé pays
l'ensemble des pays même les pays
d'europe centrale et orientale ont
finalement accepté de participer à cette
répartition et je trouve regrettable que
quelques leaders vous avez mentionné un
premier ministre aujourd'hui disent
qu'ils veulent faire des recours contre
cette décision qui a été prise à la
majorité qualifiée et quand en fait ils
ne veulent pas participer les perçages
parce qu'on voit bien que le groupe
devise gradins qui repoussé la pologne
et la hongrie donc revivre et dans l'est
la république tchèque l'acceptent
il ya d'autres pays d'europe centrale et
orientale qui sont pas d'un gros devise
râle mais qui sont proches comme la
roumanie et la bulgarie qu'ils acceptent
mais il accepte le principe mais dacia
ciolos le premier ministre roumain
rejette le principe de quota et
d'obligation de d'avoir lu à prendre en
charge aussi ces populations on voit
bien que globalement il y a une vraie
fracture au sein de l'union européenne
sur cette question et la preuve en est
que sur cent soixante mille demandes
enfin proposition de relocalisation
seulement quelques centaines ont été
mises en oeuvre en l'espace de quelques
mois à la fin de l'année ajouté oui à la
fin de l'an dernier c'était seulement
274 voilà donc comment bien pour
aujourd'hui
c est en train d'augmenter notamment
parce que la france a fait en sorte de
pouvoir accueillir ce qu'elle s'est
engagée à accueillir
vous savez sur ses 160 mille années
shell rock'n roll un problème les
prochaines années trente mille devrait
être lui en france et donc nous
respecterons cet engagement il faut tous
les états membres respectent cet
engagement et vous avez raison dire
qu'on a vu apparaître une fracture
il ya une fracture entre l'europe du
nord et l'europe du sud et puis
peut-être entre l'europe de l'ouest et
l'europe de l'est
il ya des pays qui n'ont pas une
tradition d'accueil de l'immigration qui
n'ont pas le même lien avec les pays de
provenance des réfugiés
qui n'ont pas d'histoire qui les a mis
en contact avec les pays du moyen-orient
ou avec les pays d'afrique mais nous
sommes l'europe nous sommes 28 à
constituer une communauté une union
européenne est donc aujourd'hui il faut
que chacun prenne sa part de cet accueil
et je pense qu'il n'est pas acceptable
que dans un certain nombre de pays on
est dit on accueillera des réfugiés que
s'ils sont telle religion que s'ils sont
chrétiens ce qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
très chrétien
le pape l'a dit lui même et je pense
qu'il faut aujourd'hui que qu'il y ait
beaucoup plus de cohésion et de
solidarité européenne est en tout cas
c'est même vous entendez monsieur le
ministre que ce discours justement n'est
plus entendable par une partie à la fois
de la population on voit que le vote
xénophobe nationaliste populiste
augmente et par une partie des
gouvernants qui estime que c'est une
forme de taux d'imposition d'un modèle
européen qui est celui de l'allemagne et
qui est si la france oui mais c'est une
grande démagogique de faire croire que
chacun des états membres seraient plus
fort pour répondre tout seul à cette
crise des réfugiés demain il peut y
avoir une crise de réfugiés qui viennent
d'autres régions du monde
il ya aussi des instabilités à alès du
continent européen
et les mêmes qui aujourd'hui refusent la
solidarité la demande pour d'autres
sujets quand la rizière à nantes il ya
eu la crise en ukraine vous on a bien vu
que les pays d'europe centrale et les
pays baltes par exemple demander à juste
titre qu'ils d'une solidarité européenne
parce qu'il y avait un pays la russie
qui ne respectaient pas le droit
international vers un pays voisin
l'ukraine avec l'annexion de la crimée
et c'est l'europe la france et
l'allemagne en particulier avec le le
format normandie les négociations de
mise qui ont été négociées actuellement
exercées pour établir un accord entre la
russie et l'ukraine ont si nous voyons
chacun face à cette crise essayez de
prôner des solutions nationales
c'est le règne de la démagogie et dans
sa focus list est en fait je crois qu'on
assisterait à la dislocation de l'europe
donc c'est vrai que c'est une année et
l'année 2016 entre le référendum
britannique
la crise du terrorisme la crise des
réfugiés chi chi chi une mise à
l'épreuve pour l'unité européenne
mais l'europe doit être à la hauteur de
ses rendez vous avec son histoire
alors justement on a vu que la grèce est
en première ligne sur cette question de
la crise des réfugiés notamment sur
l'île de lesbos voit que l'autriche
appel à une sortie de là
grèce de l'espace schengen parce que la
grèce est incapable de gérer cette
frontière externe qui est quand même la
plus grosse compte hier extérieures de
l'europe sachant que ce ne sont que des
vilains donc à gérer c'est quand même
compliqué et dans l'autre sens cette
solidarité des pays européens qui
doivent envoyer des moyens logistiques
et des moyens humains pour justement
permettre à frontex de faire son travail
n'est toujours pas au rendez vous alors
est-ce qu'on est ce le soldat grec se
noyait tout seul face à cette crise dont
la grèce a besoin de solidarité et il
n'est pas question d'une sortie de la
grèce de schengen ce serait une fausse
réponse ce serait même une grave erreur
au contraire nous avons besoin de
renforcer la coopération avec la grèce
si la grèce n'était pas d'un châle guen
elle n'aurait plus de raison d'ailleurs
de participer à cette coopération
il ya des aspects de cette coopération
qui relève d'ailleurs de la sécurité la
plus absolue
il faut en particulier qu'on sache si ce
qui arrive en grèce sont bien détenteur
de vrais passeports si si l'on
l'identité qui correspond à leurs
passeports s'ils ne sont pas liés à des
réseaux terroristes
donc non seulement il ya la protection
du droit d'asile la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière mais il ya la
protection dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
donc nous nous en place par ces hotspots
donc ça passe par ces hotspots mais
peut-être plus largement et c'est la
proposition que la france a fait ça
passe par la mise en place de garde
frontières européens
nous pensons qu'il faut considérablement
renforcé les moyens de l'agencé frontex
que aujourd'hui ceux qui simplement
quelques centaines de personnes même si
on a beaucoup augmenté déjà ses moyens
or on voit bien que quand il ya une
crise urgente migratoire un des pays de
l'espace schengen
il faut que les autres pays puissent
venir en aide donc il faut que l' agence
européenne dispose de personnel beaucoup
plus important parce que la police de
l'air et des frontières de la grèce elle
toute seule ne peut pas suffire
et il faut même qu'il y ait une réserve
de personnel qui peut représenter 2 %
par exemple de la police des frontières
de chaque pays qui puisse est
mobilisable immédiatement sur demande de
la commission européenne en accord avec
un état membre concerné par exemple la
grèce pour venir en appui de l' agence
européenne donc c'est ce système
européen de garde frontières et ce corps
permanent de gardes frontières européens
qu'il nous faut maintenant mettre entre
dernière question monsieur miss nous
fêtons les landes alexis tsipras ce au
pouvoir diriez-vous qu'on a été trop
loin dans l'humiliation qu'on a fait
subir au peuple grec qui a voté pour
un changement qui se retrouvent
aujourd'hui à revivre encore sous un
plan de rigueur est face à une troïka
qui impose ses vues du moins c'est comme
ça que c'est perçu aux grecs
bon la france a vraiment été au côté de
la grèce pendant toute cette négociation
pour permettre qu'il y ait un accord
avec l'ensemble des pays de la zone euro
qui empêche la sortie de la grèce de la
zone euro
nous croyons que l'austérité n'est pas
une réponse à la crise qu'a subies la
grèce il y avait des éléments de cette
crise qui était lié à des facteurs
internationaux il y avait des éléments
qui étaient liés à une mauvaise gestion
papa du gouvernement de type rase des
gouvernements précédents
donc il fallait des réformes ces
réformes c'est toujours difficile de les
faire on le voit dans tous les pays mais
là il y avait une modernisation de
l'administration une lutte contre la
corruption
le fait de faire payer des impôts à tout
le monde réforme de certains systèmes
sociaux comme les retraites cv
effectivement très difficile moi je
crois que le gouvernement d' alexis
tsipras à cellectis ypres assume m ont
fait preuve de beaucoup de courage et
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont besoin de
beaucoup de solidarité de la part de
l'europe notamment dans la renégociation
de la dette
merci beaucoup merci
non
c'était il y a un en choisissant alexis
tsipras ce les grecs disait non à
l'austérité mais à l'épreuve du pouvoir
le jeune premier ministre a déçu
beaucoup de ceux qui voyaient en lui une
alternative à commencer par les plus
jeunes qui ont massivement voté pour lui
direction athènes à leur rencontre avec
samia de sheer antonis 22 ans et
d'étudiants en économie pour payer ses
études l'été ils travaillent en
allemagne où ont été migrés ses parents
en grèce plus d'un jeune sur deux est au
chômage
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
quitter le pays
salut salut après les examens tu vas
faire quoi toi c'est ma dernière année à
la fac je suis inquiet pour l'avenir
qu'est ce que je vais faire et tu penses
à partir je sais pas je vais d'abord
faire mon service militaire
anthony lui a déjà fait son choix
ok je pense que je vais pas retirer mon
problème ce n'est pas que j'ai peur de
ce que je vais trouver à l'étranger mais
que je suis forcé de partir fatigué par
cinq ans d'austérité
des milliers de jeunes comme anthony ont
voté syriza en janvier 2015
mais six mois plus tard alexis tsipras
s'accepte un nouveau prêt des créanciers
un accord que les grecs avaient pourtant
refusé une semaine plus tôt par
référendum
les jeunes se sentent trahis annonce le
départ aux beautés series en septembre
et je ne vois pas comment un jeune peut
voter syriza maintenant si mais pas fou
s'il est avéré ne pas être radical butin
parmi les concessions du premier
ministre aux créanciers une nouvelle
réforme des retraites
le vendredi c'est jour de marché pour
retina et son mari giorgos on va acheter
des pommes au stand de pagnes otis et
par le poids et archos a commencé à
travailler dans le bâtiment à l'âge de
13 ans quand il prend sa retraite en
2000 il touche alors 1600 euros par mois
50 d'austérité plus tard il a perdu un
tiers de sa pension réduite à 1180 euros
mensuels la vie est devenue très chère
ma retraite n'est pas suffisante même
pas pour la moitié du moins voilà où on
en est après le marché giorgos rejoint
ses amis au café
ici on discute foot et politique
alexis tsipras se prépare une nouvelle
réforme des retraites réclamée par les
créanciers pour giorgos qui a voté
series 1 la pilule ne passe pas d'un
pétard nous a dit qu'il allait nous
redonner les 13ème et 14ème mois
il a promis ça et d'autres choses et
maintenant il a tout oublié
maintenant il nous dit ils m'ont mis le
couteau sous la gorge
et alors papandréou samaras ils avaient
tous le couteau sous la gorge et au
final c'est notre gauche qui s'occupait
à demain je ne fais pas la bise non non
balade ya plein de virus
mâtina je suis rentré giorgos sait que
sa conscience aura sans doute amputé une
nouvelle fois et ce n'est pas seulement
son niveau de vie et celui de sa femme
qui sont en jeu les un peu de sel ont
pas failli j'aime beaucoup mes enfants
parce que mon fils est au chômage
qui doit payer les taxes de sa voiture
sa taxe d'habitation c'est moi qui paye
tout ça maintenant fort on est comme on
peut on est devenu la conte avec allez
olla aux appétits à tina est déçu par la
politique de syriza
mais pour elle elle excite si price
n'avait pas le choix
la zone affichent un accord ils n'ont
pas laissé agir type race ils lui ont
fait la guerre et il continue voilà
comment je le vois ils ne l'ont pas
laissé agir lit les étrangers ni les
grecs
elle remontera donc pour lui pas
question en revanche pour giorgos il a
perdu confiance en la politique et en
l'union européenne je ne crois pas dans
l'europe telle qu'elle est en tout cas
ça c'est pas l'union européenne c'est
une nouvelle occupation
nous sommes les esclaves des intérêts de
la dette l'allemagne et ses alliés font
tout ce qu'ils veulent et nous nous
sommes les esclaves en grèce près de la
moitié des retraités vit aujourd'hui
sous le seuil de pauvreté
après la réforme la retraite minimum
garanti pourrait tomber à 384 euros
alexis tsipras sa promis de ne pas aller
trop loin dans les coupes
mais le bras de fer avec les créanciers
s'annonce difficile
et voilà pour ce reportage à athènes de
samia de chirée pour en parler si
amandine crespy que j'accueille bonjour
un jour vous êtes politologue à l'ulb
l'université libre de bruxelles
amandine crespy quand vous entendez
giorgos dire c'est une nouvelle
occupation nous sommes les esclaves des
intérêts de la dette
diriez-vous qu'il a raison ou qui lui va
peut-être un peu fort évidemment c'est
le point de vue de quelqu'un qui se
trouve dans une situation très difficile
comme une grande partie de la population
grecque qui subit cette austérité
je dirais sans pitié le problème étant
bien entendu que le la question de la
dette grecque n'est toujours pas résolue
donc c'est sans fin et donc cela crée un
manque de perspectives et d'espoir pour
tous ces gens alors est ce que c'est une
nouvelle occupation
il y a eu des tentatives entre les
européens de créer des mécanismes de
solidarité financière
il ya eu des des milliards de garanties
par les états soutenu également par les
contribuables ou en tout cas les
contribuables de certains états
européens
là où il y as je dirais une contrainte
et un manque de débat c'est sur cet
échange ce deal de solidarité financière
contre des réformes et donc c'est sur la
nature des réformes et le modèle qu'il
n'y a pas de consensus soit là
exactement donc ses 86 milliard pour le
dernier plan dette qui a été accouchée
dans la douleur en juillet dernier
contre 220 réformes qui doivent être
mises en oeuvre de manière progressive
par le gouvernement de chypre as il ya
la réforme des retraites dont on en
parle dans ce reportage mais il ya
effectivement des privatisations et c
est ce qu a la clé quand vous dites
qu'il n'ya pas de débat autour de ces
questions c'est une question globale un
haut niveau européen laisser austérité
rigueur coin bar en grèce que l'europe
est condamnée à l'austérité à la rigueur
et à gérer sa dette
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
l'analyse qui a été faite par les
européens en tout cas une majorité d
des décideurs ceux qui ont le pouvoir
les états créanciers les états qui sont
dans une arme en allemagne notamment
l'allemagne mais pas uniquement les pays
bas la finlande dans une certaine mesure
également le royaume uni qui ne soit pas
dans la zone euro c'est que la faiblesse
de l'euro et de la zone euro et qu'il
n'y avait pas eu au cours des années 90
de convergence sur un modèle économique
et de rattrapage économique des pays du
sud
et c'est cela que l'allemagne tente
maintenant de réaliser à m pour être
clair land entre ce qu on a mis en place
une monnaie unique
sauf que on a mis ça en place sur des
économies qui ne se valent pas les unes
les autres
tout à fait et on pensait que le
rattrapage en termes de compétitivité de
prospérité allait venir de lui même est
en fait la monnaie unique a caché un
certain nombre de disparités qui ont
persisté
le débat actuel qui n'a pas lieu c'est
est ce que il est possible et ce qu'il
est souhaitable que chaque pays
européens s'efforcent au prix de
réformes extrêmement dur de converger
vers le modèle allemand un modèle
libéral qui s'accommode et qui essayent
d'encadrer le capitalisme financier et
d'être compétitif notamment par
l'exportation au niveau global donc
c'est vraiment cette convergence à
marche forcée que l'on un modèle
allemand finalement que même la france
on le voit bien n'est pas capable
d'atteindre donc pour les autres pays du
sud de l'europe ça paraît encore plus
compliqué non
oui il n'est pas capable d'atteindre
tout à fait néanmoins le problème c'est
que aucune force politique et notamment
les socialistes et les sociaux
démocrates n'ont jusqu'à présent proposé
deux voies alternatives de modèles
alternatifs suffisamment crédible pour
engager un véritable débat sur deux
visions
différentes de vision alternative qui
permettrait de moderniser les économies
européennes qui en ont besoin
on voit qu'il ya un besoin
d'alternatives et on voit aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y a jamais eu autant de rejet de
l'europe
jean claude juncker dit bien dans son
discours sur l'état de l'union lorsqu'il
a pris son poste que c'est la commission
de la dernière chance le risque c'est ça
c'est soit on fini par dissoudre ce
qu'on a créé soit on est condamné à
trouver une alternative peut être que
social démocrate
on ne peut pas prédire l'avenir il est
aussi possible qu'en se maintiennent
finalement dans cette situation parce
que on n'a jamais organisé de référendum
au niveau européen au final on ne sait
pas et ça c'est le problème aussi de la
séparation en espaces politiques
nationaux ne sais pas si ce modèle
libéral finalement n'importe pas la
majorité de l'opinion au sein
des différentes sociétés européennes
mais il est vrai que les aspirations au
changement et à des alternatives en tout
cas à une possibilité de débat entre
alternative mac c'est vraiment ça qui
est important
ces aspirations sont très fortes
effectivement l'union européenne se
trouve dans une situation très critique
parce que ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
et c'est un mouvement de fond qui se
poursuit
c'est un remodelage des systèmes
politiques nationaux non plus autour du
clivage gauche droite mais autour un
clivage entre ceux qui veulent qu'ils
pensent que le retour à la souveraineté
nationale
la résolution et serait une solution
plus souhaitable en tous cas que la
contrainte européenne telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui
bah écoute et merci beaucoup avant d'une
critique pour ses éclairages c'est fini
pour cette semaine la semaine prochaine
vous retrouvez ahmed tazir depuis
strasbourg ciao